Good morning John, today I'm going to talk about numbers.
Numbers are great because we can't really understand the world
It's too big
There is, for example no way for me to really understand what a million of something is.
Two, I got two. Two is just one thing twice.
But two million?!
(Confused Hank noises)
As an example
I know how long a second is, and I know how many a million is
It's just a thousand thousands, and a thousand is just ten hundreds
I can say those words, and so then I should be able to know how long it was a million seconds ago.
But I can't, I have no idea
It could be a week ago, it could be a month ago, it could be a year ago.
In fact, let's do a scientific expirement right now.
Everybody write in the comment box, no math allowed, no google searches
how long ago you think it was a million seconds ago,
like how many days, or months or years you think it was.
Now I'm going to look it up, and I'm going to tell you the answer.
It was, the Monday before last a million seconds ago.
Interestingly, a billion, also a big number.
A billion seconds ago it was not, like, last month, it was not last year, it was 1982.
So by going from million to billion, we went from the  Monday before last
to, like, Michael Jackson's Thriller, and E.T., and the Falklands War.
A billion to a trillion seconds ago, we're going from 1982 to 31 thousand years ago
when humans were first being introduced to Europe.
"Hello, it is nice to meet you, Europe."
I don't know who was doing the introductions, also probably they didn't speak English.
And it goes the other way too, like, small, tiny, super super tiny small amounts of time
like a nanosecond, you've heard of a nanosecond
but how? It's the amount of time it takes for light to travel a foot.
Remember a billion seconds ago was 1982?
A billion nanoseconds ago was, by definition, one second ago.
And yet, check this out,
the fastest computer in the world can do 17 million calculations
in one nanosecond.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET MY MIND AROUND THAT
It's amazing to me, because nobody really internalizes that information
but it allows humanity to control the world and to do so many amazing and cool things
For example:  all that math allowed us to put the Kepler space telescope in orbit
where it told us that there are between 15 and 30 billion Earth-like planets in our one galaxy
and there are more than 100 billion galaxies in the observable universe.
and the observable universe is who knows how big of a fraction of the actual universe
which may , in fact, be infinite.
NO EDGE!
Giving us yet more incomprehensible data about how amazing our universe is.
We're not designed to understand that stuff, but we are designed to want to understand it.
Which, I may be wrong, that that is the most wonderful quality of humans.
This is going back to a previous conversation if you're confused.
It may, in fact, be our capacity and tendency to collaborate with each other
to make things bigger than ourselves.
There have also been people in the comments suggesting that empathy
is the most wonderful human quality
and that may also be true.
I just kinda like the fact that there are just so many different, underappreciated reasons
that humans are, in the end, pretty cool.
Nerdfighter pumpkin contest, going well
plenty of time to continue your submissions
There have even been people who have planned nerdfighter pumpkin carving meetups.
That's awesome.
Additionally, I've heard that things are getting a little boring at the DFTBA warehouse
So: every package that is not a poster gets one of these
with a hanklerfish on it.
If you only have posters in your order you won't get one
because we can't fit them in the poster tubes without ruining them.
You will, however, get a free DFTBA wristband.
I did these hanklerfishes while watching a show called Call the Midwife on Netflix.
You should watch that show, it's super good.
I cried, like a thousand times, but it's very good.
If you're more in the mood for a book, this is a quick one by Neil Gaiman: The Ocean at the End of the Lane,
which is beautiful. And this is Losers in Space by John Barnes.
It is an excellent introduction to hard science fiction, if you've ever been interested in that.
If you want to hear me ask some of the smartest people I know when they thought
a million seconds ago was, I made a video about that it's on Hank's channel.
I also participated in TALK, a YouTube channel where people talk about interesting things.
This week on TALK, people were talking about online education.
John, I will see you on Tuesday.